the perimeter of tina's rectangular
garden is 60 feet if the length of the
garden is twice the width the length is
twice the width what are the dimensions
of the garden so let's draw this garden
here tina's garden so it's a rectangle
they tell us that it's a rectangular
garden so it looks something like this
and let's say that this is the width so
this is the width then this is also
going to be the width and this is the
length up here and they tell us that the
length of the garden is twice the width
so if this is w then the length is going
to be 2w it's going to be twice the
width this is also going to be 2w over
here now what's the perimeter of this
garden well it's going to be w plus w
plus 2w plus 2w let me write this down
the perimeter of this garden is going to
be equal to
w
plus 2w
plus w
plus 2w
which is equal to what this is w plus 2w
is 3w
4w
6w so this is equal to 6w that's the
perimeter in terms of the width but they
also tell us that the actual the actual
numerical value of the perimeter is 60
feet
it is 60 feet so this perimeter 6w must
be equal to
60 if we assume that we're dealing with
feet so we just have the equation 6w is
equal to sixty we can divide both sides
of this equation by six so that we have
just a w on the left hand side six w
divided by six is just w
and then sixty divided by six is ten
so we have w is equal to ten so this the
width of the garden is ten so this
distance over here is ten
and then what is the length of the
garden well it's two times the width so
this is equal to twenty
the length is equal to 20 and so we're
done this is a 20 by 10 garden